the heartland of Tamriel she's ailing
maybe beyond saving but I'm sure you'll
take a fair crack at it all the same
welcome to Cyrano
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
since bethesda released skyrim back in
2011 modding team spanning the globe
have taken it upon themselves to
recreate all of Tamriel it's an
ambitious long-term project that aims to
release new areas as they are completed
right now you can get a taste of the
project with beyond Skyrim Bruma a
region of Cyrodiil that's located
directly south of Skyrim however Bruma
is only the first step in a marathon
according to the beyond Skyrim website
there are seven regions being recreated
using Bethesda's modding tool iliac bay
to the west which consists of high rock
and Hammerfell moro into the east sea
Radel in the center of Tamriel ELLs wire
and black marsh to the south and atmora
Andross cria
north of skyrim each of these regions
have unique cultures climates
infrastructures architecture vegetation
and politics to say this project is
ambitious is a huge understatement
what's more is that beyond Skyrim relies
entirely on volunteers and plans to
release all of these mods for free now
this isn't the first time something like
this has been attempted in fact Tamriel
rebuilt a community recreating Tamriel
within Elder Scrolls threes engine still
delivers regular updates and when
oblivion released in 2006 modders
attempted to create something similar
with fors improved engine but that never
quite came to fruition at least to the
same extent as Tamriel rebuilt modders
use the now-defunct website so grad
tower as a hub for creators to
collaborate and share their work with
one another unfortunately many modders
were dissatisfied with how these
large-scale worlds based mods were
handled as beyond Skyrim's website puts
it too much effort had been scattered
across too many projects with
duplication of effort and lack of
resource sharing becoming an endemic
problem in the community so as Skyrim's
release date approached the community
began to discuss how these large-scale
mods should be handled
while beyond Skyrim wasn't the idea of a
single person or team the website points
to a post started by candle master on
the beth soft forums that ignited the
spark that led to beyond Skyrim rather
than unifying different teams to create
the entirety of Tamriel beyond Skyrim
along with dark creation
a hub for modders was used as a vehicle
to coordinate with different teams share
resources and give all the teams a
single platform to share their creations
with fellow modders and the world apart
from a set of rules and procedures
outlined in the beyond Skyrim
Constitution the only caveat is that
these regions have to be lore friendly
take place around the same time as the
events of Skyrim and the overall quality
must be on par or exceed that of Elder
Scrolls 5 but again the team behind
Serie Dell and Bruma is only one of
seven each of these teams have their own
design philosophies region specific
resources and different stories to tell
rich Marin one of the leads for serie
Dell related it to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe all of these separate mods are
free to tell their own stories but the
developers are aware that these
creations and stories should fit within
the larger universe that beyond Skyrim
has put forth for example one team can't
create a quest line that destroys all of
Tamriel
Maran has been modding for six years now
he began on a project to recreate souls
time a small region northeast of Skyrim
however weeks into the project Bethesda
announced Dragonborn an expansion that
took place in the very same region they
were recreating the project was
shuttered and rich took notice of an
inactive serie del project without a
lead he threw his name in the running
and with some help from Marcus Liberty a
creative who helped with Bruma he got
the position over the years beyond
Skyrim has unified certain aspects of
development such as voice acting and the
music department in fact the music
you're hearing in this video was
composed by Daniel ran for beyond Skyrim
Bruma
[Music]
but a lot of these decisions are left to
the autonomous teams while new ideas
still need to be vetted the cyrodiil
team is open to experimentation even if
it doesn't quite sink up with the lure
and that's one of the many things that's
so cool about this project as messy as
Elder Scrolls lore can get there is so
much room for interpretation and
untapped potential most developers build
off their Laura's new titles release but
these mods have the power to give us a
fresh and vastly different take on areas
that were explored years ago or only
referenced and Bruma alone I can already
see how the team is planting seeds for a
larger plot line and I couldn't be more
excited to see where they take it and I
hear rumors whispers on the wind of
insurrectionist groups agitating against
the current government there are so many
opportunities to explore here take iliac
bay a few weeks ago the team released a
beautiful trailer for their mod and it's
brimming with potential sure we saw high
rock and hammer fell in the elder
scrolls too but never quite like this
seeing lush jungles and deserts is not
only a breath of fresh air but it holds
thousands of new possibilities and
scenarios that we would have never
experienced in Skyrim what Larry and Meg
Lowe Smith team are doing with morrowind
is another perfect example of that in
the official lore morrowind was
devastated by a volcano before the
events of Skyrim things are very
different than what you remember from
the Elder Scrolls 3 and the morrowind
team is embracing that parts of the
world are caked with ash and a smoky
haze hangs over the province the
prospect of this is even more
interesting if you consider the fact
that we may never see what Marlin looked
like after the volcano erupted in any
official capacity the mod is
appropriately titled morrowind the star
wounded east
[Music]
both meg Lowe's and Larry enjoined the
Morrowind team in 2016 after a shift in
direction and reshuffling of leadership
that who found themselves as directors
while they stick to lore whenever
possible they get a lot of inspiration
from the Tamriel rebuilt team the
geography on the other hand is pieced
together from multiple sources once
again the team considers Tamriel rebuilt
as their primary source but many of the
locations from Elder Scrolls online also
appear in their vision of morrowind when
I asked Marin about all these different
directions the mods are going he said
that he thinks it beyond Skyrim as a
huge collection of work for folks who
are trying to break into the industry or
bolster their portfolios in fact Larian
one of the directors on morrowind is
hoping for this to be his foot in the
door once he's done with school
as of now the only beyond Skyrim mod
available is Bruma it adds the Jerell
Mountains in the frigid city of Bruma
with the mod installed you can find a
border crossing on the southern end of
Skyrim after convincing the guards to
let you through you take your first
steps in serie dell having played around
15 hours of this mod the first thing i
noticed was how professional it looks
the voice acting branching narratives
and quests design is as good if not
better at times than anything you'd see
in a Bethesda Game Studios RPG plus it
has its fair share of weird quests which
I personally love yes the nirn theater
the center stage of the imperial city of
the world they cast me out the
irredeemable fools
according to Moran beyond Skyrim Bruma
originally began as a proof-of-concept
the scope was much smaller and the main
focus would be on the city itself after
promising a summer 2014 release date the
team decided that if they did hit that
release window they would have to
drastically cut back on content and the
level of polish wouldn't be up to par
back in July we came to a difficult
decision we were going to delay beyond
Skyrim Bruma we had announced it on our
Facebook page but we decided to announce
it here also to make sure everyone is
aware
it wasn't until 2017 that the mod
finally released and it's clear that all
that extra time went to good use there
were more quests more creatures an
original score and more detail
overall the completed model or like an
overly ambitious expansion than a demo
of what's to come three more years might
sound like a long time but creating
something even of this scale is a
massive endeavor these large-scale mods
begin with a height map a low poly
aerial map of a landmass then for Bruma
at least the assets like buildings
weapons dungeons armor sets and
vegetation are created we are talking
thousands of individually crafted items
even something as simple as the iron
weapons from Skyrim or redesigned for
Bruma after the space has been molded
these assets are added and then quests
characters and storylines are
implemented then you have to consider
voice acting music sound effects bug
testing performance animations interiors
balancing NPC routes
text found in books scattered throughout
the world and so on the point is in
order to create something of this
caliber it requires a lot of time and
their work is starting to really pay off
the Bruma trailer has over 1 million
views on YouTube nearly a million
downloads on Nexus mods and a quarter of
a million downloads on Xbox one and it
sounds like this success is exciting for
the other teams as well according to Meg
lows from the morrowind team Bruma
really put them on the map many more
people became aware of this project and
in turn more people joined the various
teams above all though it proved to them
that what they were trying to achieve
could actually be done
however Marin isn't sure if this success
will continue forever like oblivion and
morrowind before this modders typically
follow the games that will get their
creations the most exposure and fans
typically care more about the latest
iteration well I can't imagine these
mods shutting down when the Elder
Scrolls 6 releases it certainly does
pose a threat the best-case scenario is
that these mods release during Skyrim's
lifecycle fortunately for the modding
teams Bethesda has stated that its next
installment is coming but it's still a
ways out and as Meg Lowe's points out
people have been modding morrowind for
over 15 years the community is still
going strong at most
meg Lewis believes that they will see a
drop in membership when six launches but
production on the mods won't halt
altogether
another common fear for a project like
this is turnover when your team is
entirely composed of volunteers you
think the workforce would come and go
frequently however Marin assured me that
that isn't necessarily the case while he
couldn't speak for the other teams the
core group behind Serie Dell has been
around for three to four years and as of
now sir Adele has roughly 40 to 50
members made up of artists audio
designers writers level designers
animators and so on but even for 50
dedicated people this is still a massive
undertaking morrowind on the other hand
has a larger headcount
however Larian did mention that 3d
artists can be difficult to hold on to
due to Skyrim stated engine 3d artists
have stricter limitations than other
departments
despite the scope of this project marin
Laren and megaliths made it clear that
life comes first as exciting and
demanding as all these projects may be
it shouldn't take priority over school
work well-being or family after all
there is no money involved in any of
these projects most of these volunteers
are trying to do the impossible while
living a life typically when we hear
about mods of this scale they either
never see the light of day or are
forgotten when they finally release it's
tough to keep a project like this going
without a significant amount of money
backing it and even harder when your
developers are largely made up of
volunteers nevertheless these teams push
onward beyond Skyrim feels like a direct
response to the failings and
shortcomings of previous standalone mods
made for Oblivion and morrowind rather
than working entirely
independent of one another that beyond
Skyrim teams have built something that
allows everyone to work toward a similar
goal while blazing their own unique
trails against all odds they are
creating something far bigger than what
the Fez de originally created in 2011
something far bigger than anything we
typically see from triple-a developers
and something that's fulfilling the
dream many never thought was possible
the dream of recreating Tamriel is
slowly becoming a reality so I think a
little patience on our end isn't too
much to ask in an industry where
publishers hide content behind paywalls
and drip feed players in order to keep
them coming back it's refreshing to see
a game that's being kept alive entirely
by the community apart from re-releases
Bethesda stopped updating Skyrim and
adding DLC years ago yet I still find
myself coming back every few months
thanks to folks like Marin Larry and Meg
Lowe's to me Skyrim no longer feels like
that janky immersive RPG Bethesda
created all those years ago
it's an adventure that's constantly
changing beneath my feet and heading in
all sorts of exciting directions I would
have never imagined it's hard to say
whether or not beyond Skyrim will hit
all those lofty goals they've set for
themselves but is someone looking in
from the outside it's clear they have
built up an infrastructure to not only
make a bigger Tamriel possible but
attainable
[Music]
you
you